There are several asian languages that
are commonly studied around the world
like mandarin japanese and korean one
asian language that's less commonly
studied but is still an important major
language
is vietnamese or as it's called in
vietnamese
vietnamese is the first language of
around 85 to 90 million people worldwide
most of them in vietnam of course while
several million vietnamese people abroad
also speak it
it's also the second language of 10 to
15 percent of vietnam's population
since there are many linguistic
minorities in vietnam vietnamese is part
of the mon khmer branch of the
austroasiatic language family
it's by far the austroasiatic language
with the most speakers
the second most spoken being khmer or
kamae
as they call it the base of vietnamese
is mon khmer
but similar to japanese and korean
vietnamese has undergone a tremendous
amount of influence from chinese
vietnam came under almost continuous
chinese rule for a period of around a
thousand years
beginning in the year 111 bce around
this time or earlier
proto-viet mong the ancestor of the
vietnamese and
wong languages arose as we'll see later
vietnamese is a tonal language
but proto-viet wong did not yet contain
any tones
it might be tempting to conclude that
vietnamese adopted its tones from
chinese but that's very unlikely
both the tones of chinese and the tones
of vietnamese arose naturally through a
process of
tonogenesis meaning that the tones arose
from other phonological features
as the proto-vietnamese language arose
from proto-vietng
it first developed three-tone
distinctions after this
by the 9th century a huge amount of
chinese vocabulary began to enter the
language
because the formal written language was
classical chinese
with characteristic vietnamese
pronunciation and attempts to write
vernacular vietnamese were made using
chinese characters
today approximately thirty percent of
commonly used words are of chinese
origin
while in formal texts that rises to
sixty percent or even seventy percent
for example this recent newspaper
headline meaning the price of jackfruit
drops to the floor farmers suffer heavy
losses
in this example 4 out of 8 words are of
chinese origin
the system of writing using entirely
chinese characters was called
or then after vietnam returned to
vietnamese rule
under the ngo dynasty a new system was
developed in which chinese characters
were used for words of chinese origin
and some native vietnamese words while
newly created characters were used for
vietnamese words
this system was called
the new characters were adaptations or
combinations of existing chinese
characters or their elements
but they weren't used in chinese we can
see an example of this in the name of
this writing system
the second character exists in chinese
but the first one doesn't
from the 15th century to the 19th
century this system was used for writing
vietnamese literature such as
the tale of qiu perhaps the most famous
vietnamese work of poetry
also by the start of this period the
three tones of vietnamese had split into
its present six
tones meanwhile classical chinese
continued to be used for official
writing and amongst the elite
this situation continued until the
french occupation of vietnam which began
in the 19th century
french replaced chinese as the language
of administration and the elite
and the french encouraged the use of to
write vietnamese
the name of the script means national
language script and is the current
writing system which is based on a
modified latin alphabet
it was first created by portuguese
missionaries in the 17th century but
didn't become widespread until the
french were in power
french influence on vietnamese also took
place in the form of loanwords
even though they may not stand out as
french because of their vietnamese
pronunciation and spelling
for example coffee cafe in french
meaning coffee in the word
from meaning railway station
from fromage meaning cheese so me
in the word comes from
meaning shirt from
meaning soap as you can see a lot of the
french loanwords are common everyday
words
but there are far fewer of them than
there are chinese loanwords
one study concluded that ninety percent
of loanwords come from chinese while
four percent come from french
if you found the pronunciation of those
french loanwords disorienting then
you've just experienced a touch of what
most learners find challenging about
vietnamese
it's phonology while vietnamese is quite
straightforward in other ways
its phonology is fairly complex standard
vietnamese doesn't officially have
standardized pronunciation
the hanoi dialect is sometimes thought
of as a de facto standard
and is the variety used in most of this
video but there are many varieties with
different pronunciation
including the dialect of ho chi minh
which is obviously an important one
northern vietnamese basically has 19
consonants
while there are 23 consonants if we
include all dialects
they're written with 16 single consonant
letters 10 consonant digraphs
and one consonant trigraph that's a
total of 27 consonant graphemes
meaning that some consonant sounds are
written in more than one way
there are 11 vowel sounds written with
12 graphemes
as well as 28 or more diphthongs and 12
or more triphthongs
standard vietnamese also has six
phonemic tones
meaning that different tones indicate a
difference in meaning
the tones are flat mid ma low falling
ma high rising ma low falling broken
ma low falling rising ma high rising
broken
ma notice that each of these syllables
is a different word with a different
meaning
for example ma means the ghost while
ma means mom when you include all the
different phonemes including tones there
are between 4
500 and 4 800 possible syllables in
spoken vietnamese depending on the
dialect
and vietnamese orthography can represent
6200 different syllables
any syllable that appears in any dialect
several learners of vietnamese whom i've
spoken to
told me that learning to produce all the
different phonemes of vietnamese
is really just a matter of practice but
that building listening comprehension
skills is the bigger challenge
but not everything about vietnamese is
difficult or complicated
its grammar is fairly straightforward
vietnamese is an analytic language
meaning that there are no inflections
and grammatical relationships between
words are shown through word order and
by adding adjacent
helper words instead this means that you
don't have to learn various forms of
words
there are no case inflections no
conjugations no grammatical genders and
no plural form
you just learn one form of each word
people sometimes refer to vietnamese as
a monosyllabic language but that's not
precisely accurate
many words have two syllables especially
compound words that consist
of two independent words put together
but if you separate those two pieces of
the word each of those pieces
is normally a meaningful independent
word on its own those words that join
together to form compound words don't
always have one syllable each but they
usually do
also it's worth noting that more
compound words are used in writing and
formal speech
so there are a lot more monosyllabic
words in colloquial speech
the basic word order of vietnamese is
svo
for example the sentence meaning he ate
dinner
here's the subject here's the verb and
here's the object
adverbs usually come after verbs and
after the object of the verb if there is
one
this means he ate dinner early
adjectives also come after the nouns
they modify
like this phrase meaning the nice
restaurant
literally restaurant beautiful so do
demonstrative adjectives
that restaurant literally restaurant
that
possessives come after nouns as well
sometimes with a possession marker
his restaurant literally restaurant
possession marker
he the possession marker is sometimes
dropped when talking about subjects such
as parents
home or school but in this case it's
necessary
in equational sentences there's no verb
meaning to be when the predicate is an
adjective
this means hong is smart but when the
predicate is a noun or a noun
phrase then the linking verb la is used
hong is a singer word for word the
sentence is hong
is singer note that vietnamese does not
have articles so this sentence has no
equivalent of the word ah
the cardinal number is sometimes used in
a way
similar to the english indefinite
article in this case it might be used to
emphasize indefiniteness
this too means hong is a singer verbs in
vietnamese always have the same form
there are no conjugations tense and
aspect is expressed with time markers
that come before the verb
this means he rides a motorbike
he rode a motorbike
he's riding a motorbike
tomorrow he will ride a motorbike there
are also some adverbs that can be used
to show the action's relationship to
time
sometimes alone and sometimes together
with a time marker
he's about to come here tomorrow to
borrow my motorbike word for word it's
he about to come here to borrow
motorbike of me the main thing to note
here is that the verb itself never
changes
another word is added to give
information about time
let's go back to the present tense
sentence and add something i'm going to
lie more just in my model
this means he rides a red motorbike word
for word it's
he ride one counter motorbike color
red this word here is a classifier or a
counter
like a unit for counting nouns that
differs depending on the category of
noun
in english there's some limited use of
words like this like a pair of pants or
sheets of paper but in vietnamese
they're much more frequently used
they come after the number and before
the noun this one's used for vehicles
and for individual items in a set of
items
these are the most common counters this
is a counter for people
for example meaning two americans
there's a different classifier for other
animate nouns which are normally animals
i have a dog for inanimate nouns there
are lots of different specific
classifiers but there's one very common
one that can be used for most inanimate
objects in general
he bought two pens note that in each of
these cases the counter comes after the
cardinal number and before the noun
now let's look at a couple of questions
and possible answers and see what we
find
this question means do you drink alcohol
not go on zero
word for word it's you confirmation
particle drink
alcohol negation marker yes or no
questions are commonly formed using the
words
which are also used to answer such a
question with yes or no
comes after the subject and comes at the
end
it's kind of like saying you do drink
alcohol no
um no i don't drink alcohol
word for word no i no drink alcohol
notice here that the negation marker
comes before the verb
yes i drink alcohol word for word it's
confirmation particle
i drink alcohol there's the confirmation
particle the same one that appears in
the question
another question this time an open
question man somewhere though
word for word it's you live in where
i live in hanoi i live in hanoi
open questions are basically formed by
substituting the question word for the
word that
answers the question some question words
come at the beginning of the sentence
and some come at the end
it's worth mentioning something about
the personal pronouns these are
basically neutral polite pronouns but
there are actually numerous different
pronouns to choose from depending on the
gender and
age or social position of the person
you're speaking to this is another one
of the challenging things for learners
of vietnamese
on the easier side personal pronouns
remain the same regardless of whether
they're a subject or an object
the examples so far have been in
northern vietnamese but vietnamese has
three main dialect groups
northern in particular hanoi central and
southern
in particular the ho chi minh dialect
naturally the northern dialect of hanoi
and the southern dialect of ho chi minh
are both popular for learners and of
course there are differences
northern vietnamese has six tones as we
saw before
while southern vietnamese has five two
of the tones represented in writing are
pronounced the same in southern
vietnamese
so in northern vietnamese there's ma and
ma in southern vietnamese there's
also the general range of pitches used
is higher in the north and lower in the
south
even though the relative contours of the
pitches are similar
another difference is that the letter d
and the digraph gi
are pronounced z in the north but ye in
the south
for example this word meaning easy in
northern vietnamese
and in southern vietnamese another
letter that's pronounced as
za in northern vietnamese is r in
southern vietnamese it's pronounced
similar to the r sound commonly used in
english
for example the word for alcohol in
northern vietnamese
and in southern vietnamese another
difference lies in the letter
v which is pronounced in northern
vietnamese but in southern vietnamese
it's
at least in casual conversation for
example the word for ticket
in northern vietnamese and in southern
vietnamese
yeah also s and x are both pronounced
si in hanoi and much of the north but in
southern vietnamese
s
for example the word for excellent in
northern vietnamese
and in southern vietnamese another
difference is that the digraphs tr
and ch are both pronounced in the north
in the south tr is pronounced and ch is
pronounced
but these days more people pronounce
them the same
there's also a significant number of
different words between the two
varieties
we can see one example in this sentence
from before
and here it is in southern vietnamese
notice the different word for pen this
is just one example but there are
numerous different words like this
as you can see vietnamese is a very
interesting language
it may not be the easiest language for
learners to take on and its phonology
may present a challenge
but in certain ways it's a very
straightforward language if you've ever
been
frustrated by cases in german or verb
conjugations in spanish
then vietnamese grammar might be a
breath of fresh air
and most learners say it's a fun
language to learn especially if you have
a growth mindset and a long-term view
for the language
the question of the day for speakers of
vietnamese how easy is it for you to
communicate with speakers of other
dialects
and for other people what's your
impression of vietnamese
what seems challenging and what seems
straightforward this is the part of the
video when i say thanks to the langfocus
patreon supporters especially these ones
right here on the screen because they
are
the top tier patreon supporters so many
extra special thanks go out to them
and to everyone thank you for watching
and have a nice
day
you